IMPACT ON TURNING A FRANCHISE
AROUND AND BECOMING A WINNING
TEAM.
HERE IN THIS PLAYOFF RUN, THE
FIRST THREE ROUNDS, DEVIN BOOKER
STARTED IN THE FIRST ROUND
AGAINST THE PLAYOFFS.
HAD A 47-POINT CLENCHING GAME
SIX.
CHRIS PAUL AT HIS BEST.
IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE FINALS
THEY HAD A LOT OF HELP FROM A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Mark: CHRIS PAUL IS
ACKNOWLEDGING LIL' WAYNE AND THE
SUPPORT AND LOVE HE HAS SHOWN
FOR THE PHOENIX SUNS AND
BELIEVING IN THEM AND SUPPORTING
THEM AND BEING AROUND THEM.
HE WANTS TO BE A PART OF THIS
CELEBRATION.
>> Mike: 41 POINTS.
DEVIN BOOKER, AFTER HAVING A
SOME STRUGGLES EARLIER IN THE
SERIES, EXCELLENT GAME TONIGHT
WITH 22 POINTS.
THEY GOT JAE CROWDER WITH A BIG
PERFORMANCE.
HE HAD 19.
PAUL IS GOING TO ENJOY THIS
BEFORE HE GETS SET.
REMEMBER, CHRIS PAUL IN GAME ONE
OF THESE PLAYOFFS INJURED HIS
RIGHT SHOULDER.
PEOPLE WERE STARTING TO SAY, OH,
NO, ANOTHER INJURY FOR CHRIS
PAUL.
THE FIRST THREE GAMES OF THAT
SERIES WAS A STRUGGLE.
HE CAME BACK STRONG.
WAS MAGNIFICENT AGAINST DENVER.
THEN MISSED TWO GAMES IN THIS
SERIES AFTER